horizon zero dawn is the next big title
from guerrilla games the team behind
Playstations Killzone franchise but we
won't be playing it this year I'm Tony
and this game spot news update is equal
parts post-apocalyptic and prehistoric
horizon zero dawn has indeed been
delayed and the new release date is set
for februari 28 2017 according to the
studio this delay quote affords us the
extra time required to deliver fully on
our ambitious vision for the game
they're not wrong about the ambitious
part horizon zero dawn features a
massive world with all types of terrain
and a full day night cycle Guerrilla
Games apologizes for the delay but
stresses that it allows them to fully
implement all of their ideas the team
also released a new trailer featuring
lead character alloy who's inspired by
female heroes from various movies and TV
shows don't be surprised if you hear
more about the game or its recently
revealed collector's editions at Sony's
e3 press conference next week to keep up
with horizon zero dawn and all the
upcoming news of e3 you already in the
right place
you